any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
you to give permission maybe maybe it
will maybe it won't
yeah talking today
with uh christopher sweat who is a
philosopher a thinker someone that i met
online as i've met most of my friends
and contacts in the last 10 years
there's some friends i have i haven't
ever met in person probably never will
some live as far away as uh uganda egypt
whatever
but today chris it's a pleasure to be
talking one-on-one again
yeah you too and the internet's a
powerful place isn't it yeah yeah it's
really amazing i have guys that uh gals
that apply for jobs to work on different
projects or internship never met them i
don't actually don't know if they're
male or female i know nothing about
and i'm sending them money and i'm you
know they could be bots who are all ido
but chris you're you're a remarkable
intellect and i know you don't feel that
word is completely free from uh maybe
overburden some uh uh character so i
wanna talk about intellectual uh uh and
being on the internet in this in this
day and age but i just want to point out
that uh i have you know really utmost
respect for for you going
back to school as you are now at one of
my you know in some sense rival
institutions because you see boulder uh
gets uh some of the best students in the
world and i'm fighting against them to
get people like you and get people like
my graduate students but anyway man
thank you so much for coming and thank
you for the effort that you're putting
into you know just your dreams and what
you're trying to do and we're going to
talk about all your cool projects but i
want you to introduce yourself what's
your world line as we say in physics
what got you to this point from where
did you come
your origin story in the science fiction
sense um tell my audience who might not
be as familiar with you from your online
work as i am
yeah 100
i think um i i think
i started out as a tinkerer as a lot of
um thinkers or experimenters kind of
started out
and i i got really lucky that my
tinkering started like around the time
that broadband internet was coming out
which doesn't seem like an advanced
invention these days and it probably
doesn't seem that advanced for some of
your young listeners but that was a huge
deal
i was uh like 10 or 11 years old so
i uh my tinkering started with um just
like simple wireless networks and
computers and uh that that moved into um
racing simulators which is like a whole
quest we could do a whole episode
talking about racing simulators which i
feel like are still it's still kind of
an underground scene
and i think
through
this different kind of experimentation i
was doing um as a young person i i got
to see how different systems interacted
with other systems
and i i got addicted to it i i like i
liked to be able to test things
in what i guess was somewhat of a
controlled space or controlled
environment
and i like to push the boundaries i like
to push the envelope
and i think my adult life has been
about
harnessing
my need or desire to push the envelope
and to take my experiments or take my
perspective or understanding and boil it
in to something that's useful um or
practica practical um you know
in a few different contexts
yeah so
it's a rare skill you know when i um
when i'm looking for interns or or
working for students or even graduate
students sometimes
um you know they'll say well i don't
have any experience you know in the lab
uh but you know my dad had a welding
shop in you know akron ohio i'm like
that's awesome you know
for experimental physics which is very
different from theoretical physics or
theoretical science and experimental
science but i think uh i'm curious do
you think we're losing a lot of that
like i have a car that was you know like
a toyota city and a minivan i i don't
know if you're a dad yet or or have any
problems yeah i got a bunch of kids and
uh you gotta get a minivan or else you
know one of my friends like before you
have kids if you get a minivan you're a
weirdo but after you have kids and you
don't get a minivan you're even more
weird i try to open the hood on that
thing once and i couldn't i couldn't do
a damn thing and i used to tinker with
my first car you know as 1970s
volkswagen i could do i could do a brake
job i could do do you think we're losing
some of that because of the kind of
relentless advance of technology of
which you're playing a big part in do
you think we're losing some of the
ability to even get under the hood
literally or figuratively
yeah the automation it seems like the
more
automation that um
exists the further we are from the basic
processes that are taking place like
just a simple example of this and maybe
you can give us a physics tie back but
think about like power steering and a
lot of people don't realize this but
there are um
there are like old school like uh rack
and pinion type steering mechanisms
where the steering wheel is actually
having a direct impact on the wheels
that are on the ground when you uh
do any kind of steering input but now a
lot of cars have like uh what's called
like a hydro electric power steering
and it's actually not responding
directly to the wheels there's a part of
the system that is in between the
steering wheel and the actual drive
wheels so you can't feel the wheels on
the ground in the steering wheel anymore
and again obviously um you could rotate
it from lock to lock with your pinky
finger that's [ __ ] sweet and you
don't have to be doing 20 or 30 miles an
hour to turn comfortably you know and
there's people that may not even
understand what i'm talking about
hopefully you're following brian yeah uh
but it seems like the more automation
that comes into um these different
systems the further we like you know the
average human being gets away from
you know the processes that are going on
because they're not involved in them
anymore yeah and i think it's it's true
in the aviation industry you know i fly
a little planes around and uh you know
certainly true the automation you know
fly by wire uh all these things uh kind
of harkens back to you know in the space
race there's a great book called digital
apollo from mit uh professor of
aerospace engineering he talks about i
forget the man's name but he talks about
how
all the lunar command module pilots guys
who were landing you know from neil
armstrong to alaska you know gene cernan
or whatever when they landed on the moon
at the it was fully automated they could
be even the computer of that time which
everyone says we could fit it in your
pocket you know the whole
that computer could land the module
completely safely but every single time
at the last second the pilot caught a
glimpse of a boulder or a crater that
had been uncharted and oh he had because
what is the highest expression of a
pilot it's landing right you don't
applaud like for the pilot and cruise
you know congratulations but when they
make a good landing uh you applaud him
or her right so um
but i feel like we we kind of are as
carl sagan said never has society been
more dependent on technology and less
you know kind of uh comprehending of
that of that technology in science um do
you feel like that's that's kind of a
a positive thing or a negative thing in
other words like can we just remove
people from having to understand i don't
understand even you know they say that
actually chris i don't know if you've
ever heard they say that there's no
person on earth who can do or understand
all the steps needed to make a pencil
like just a yellow pencil right all the
different so do you think that's a like
a good thing like it's i don't need to
know how a pencil is made to use it but
do you think there's um you know virtue
to that or is it or is it leading us in
a dangerous place
i mean i probably have
i probably have still what's like
considered an underground opinion on
this but
but i guess automation ties into labor
and that i've heard people make these
arguments that the more
automation
that is created the more different types
of processes that exist
they think that we're entering this era
of like hyper specialization
which they think is uh potentially
detrimental because it'll make it to
where at some point in some distant
future everyone's job will be so
specialized that um you know
uh
it'll just be some specialized
repetitious thing we'll all be like a
like a janitor or a call center employee
or some something like that and i don't
believe that i don't think that we're
going to have a scenario where we won't
still need highly specialized high
skilled labor
but
i do think that
my opinion is that the technology is
getting away from a lot of people
and i don't like it because when i try
to
advance or extend thinking
there's a lot of people that are still
stuck in an old model that i think like
doesn't let the technology have as much
room as it needs to produce
i don't know a more
efficient future or a more
capable future and it seems like you
have these like special domains like
aerospace
um or
uh you have these other domains that are
like super concentrated on real specific
expertise and those domains can move uh
through these kind of waves of
technological advancements in many ways
uh more quickly than domains that have a
broader reach or maybe um require more
people to be involved like something
silly like
like some kind of enterprise software
like salesforce for example there's
millions of people that work in and out
of salesforce and so you have so many
such a wide variance of skills and
abilities in that system and and
different environments that it gets
deployed into whereas like us how many
spacecraft are you know
uh flying on any given sunday right
um
what were you like as a kid were you
like you know kind of kid who just like
wanted to play with chemistry sets and
was frustrated because they stopped
including radium in those chemistry sets
like when i was a kid uh were you more
of a digital tinkerer as you are now um
and then you know kind of delve into
take us back tell the story of of your
kind of upbringing what brought you to
this you know kind of
uh sense that i think you have the
rarest trait of all upcoming guest uh
ryan holidays coming on the show to talk
about courage i think it takes a lot of
courage to do what you're doing i'm you
know i don't even think i didn't even
know how old you were until you told me
but but um but you know at any age to do
it non-traditionally my mother went back
to college got her bachelor's her
master's in social work she was in her
50s 60s
after having me and you know ruining her
academic career but talk us through that
where did you get that pretty natural
courage is it inborn is a gift is it is
it just based on hard work where does
that come from and uh what were you like
what was your kind of things that
fascinated you as a 12 year old which i
assume
plays no small role in who you are now
yeah okay
whatever happened to me as a young child
i don't know because i um i've always
spoken outside of my pay grade or
whatever expertise people think should
be available to me
so like when i was running on like this
hardcore simulators everyone was in
their 20s and 30s but i was 11 12 13 14.
some of these people still keep up with
me two decades later because apparently
they couldn't believe what we were doing
because these simulators took practice
like you know they took tons of
iteration
and a lot of people slide to have like
some physical reference point whereas
when you're in a simulator it's all
based off a visual
reference point so i was obviously like
uh
making highly sophisticated inferences
with super limited information right
which i guess apparently is a unique
skill right yeah um
but uh i didn't have uh any like
academic
support or like i wasn't showing like
any of these traditional markers of
intelligence or
early success it was not in any of these
gifted programs frankly by the time i
got to high school i didn't care
i think i finished high school with a
1.8 gpa
and some of the classes that i got bad
grades in i'm like that doesn't even
make sense
so so there was always this dual life of
i had these interests that i was
excelling in that were clearly advanced
right
um but the school system
somehow i just slipped through the
cracks i i i can't explain it i slipped
through the cracks
so i if i look back to when i was young
and it's probably it's still like this
now but i think i've always been
somewhat of a lone wolf
you know i i have friends from different
circles but but i think i've always been
somewhat of a lone wolf i i liked
mountain biking when i was younger
uh you know i
listened to my discman i would try to
get the best skip protection possible so
that my cd would keep
rotating and i could hear the audio
yeah
and then again i did so i did so much on
the computer that computers and the
internet have been
second nature to me for as long as i can
remember which is like you know why with
covid or like having devices anywhere
all this stuff is just feels like what
what i've always been accustomed to it
doesn't feel like anything new
necessarily
so you weren't like that kid who drove
your parents crazy you know trying
trying to take uh the the computer the
router apart at home to see if you could
uh speed up the though no it's wild
i was empowered to do those things so i
gotta i have to thank my mom for that
she she like empowered me to
experiment um in the areas that i don't
know she must have noticed i
might have had some kind of strength
there yeah so i was always empowered to
uh tinker around with uh you know like
wireless hardware computers bikes
you know any system that i could get my
hands on
uh
and but the issue is that a lot of my
friends that share some of these
characteristics are introverted yes and
uh there's only one person in my life
that thinks i'm introverted but she'll
figure it out one day
uh everyone sees me as hardcore
extroverted and super gregarious and
outgoing so
i would say i'm probably somewhere in
the middle but i've always been
outspoken about what i can see or what
i'm observing and that's the confidence
and the courage i spoke about earlier
with you
because you know a lot of people
wouldn't be doing this you know getting
a bachelor's degree you you you're doing
what this guy austin cleon i think calls
he calls you know showing your work like
you're developing stuff in public and i
think that is kind of you know it was
interesting and i like to get your take
on this but um i've been you know my new
book is about like the imposter syndrome
overcoming that and but there's like two
different signs to that because it comes
from insecurity like i'm not good enough
to do it but then i was thinking um in
an interview i was you know just kind of
thinking out loud which is always
dangerous but
um but it's still
i think has a kernel of truth that the
opposite of the imposter syndrome is
also based on insecurity and that's
arrogance like when people have like
argument narcissistic tendencies i think
a lot of times they're really insecure
and they're just covering up for it with
bravado and bluster but i think yeah
this notion of of creating in public of
you know not listening to i don't care
what what you think i should do what my
friend james allthutcher says you know
choosing yourself like who needs these
gatekeepers and and that's why i think
again you know not to like you know make
this a love fest but but going back to
school that decision i think is very uh
is very telling about your character
because a lot of people wait for the
gatekeepers you know when we're in high
school
uh you know some of us that got you know
maybe a 2.8 gpa
not no one but i mean we were i was
concerned getting into a good college
why so i could go to a good grad school
why so i could get a good post up why so
i could get an assistant professor why
yes i could get tenure why so i could
you know win a nobel prize you know
whatever
sure but um but you're not listening to
that so why boulder i mean you made you
mo you were on the east coast before
right
nah actually i've been well i'm in
washington right now but i'm sorry
you're in question yeah yeah right i'll
be in boulder tomorrow because i still
split the time right but um actually i
so i grew up
until age 10 in the bay area and then i
moved to colorado and i was very young
colorado springs
i actually spent 11 years in denver
metro
so boulder is like um
i mean my last place in colorado before
putting one in boulder was at the edge
of boulder county they probably hung out
in boulder like three times a week i i
worked in 2014 i worked for an
enterprise tech startup in boulder
boulder's always been like up the street
from me yeah i've got lots of friends in
boulder county and for me
honestly i was told by some mentors in
the bay area that maybe i should be a
little bit more
ambitious with where i applied and i
heard that but then i kind of also
decided that
boulder is still a respected school
in most parts of the country and i'm
pretty sure i'll be able to take
whatever i do at boulder
and transfer to uh top 20 as long as i
perform well
um but yeah it's a community i've spent
a lot of time in i actually love that
town as nuanced as it is there's things
i hate about it but many things that i
love about it
yeah it's uh it's got kind of the you
know big city adjacent but it's got the
you know small town it's got the
national laboratory
university i think i could you know
pretty much exist anywhere there's a
some kind of college or university i
think you need that you know life of the
intellectual and there i want to pivot
uh clumsily to intellectual
ism and you know one of the first rooms
i ever met you on clubhouse you're very
prolific uh was a rant that you were
doing which is the title of your sub
stack which we'll put uh links to in the
show notes and uh refer to i'm
subscribed actually twice under two
different videos so so you're i'm
inflating your your sub count
as you deserve but i met you in a room
on clubhouse a long time ago all right
we after i met but i was i was you know
kind of just just really curious and
listening and you had a room title like
can we talk about you know
black
public intellectuals yep
and again chris again this is whatever
i'm not going to apologize but you know
it was like kind of courageous because
you're you're going out there and that's
like kind of a third rail in in in in
the public intellectual i don't even
know what a public like would you call
me a jewish intellect i mean i know a
lot of people that wouldn't say i'm an
anti-intellectual but uh but the point
being you know it's such a loaded term
and then you add another you know kind
of loaded term on top of that black and
and um
you know but you're just like unafraid
you'll just take it on and so i want to
talk about that and then we'll get into
your your sub stack and specifically
your most recent post which you know as
a paying subscriber no i don't know if i
have to pay anything but you haven't
updated in a while man you gotta you
gotta put out a new rant i'm really
jonesing for it but talk about what is a
black intellectual do they exist are you
one uh you know how how does that term
make you how do you react to that
yeah no actually i've tried to be
critical of the idea of a black
intellectual from so many angles now so
we'll have to catch people up in a few
short minutes yeah uh
but i think that black intellectual
obviously served a purpose in society
when there weren't many ways for
uh
groups to communicate with uh these
certain parts of the black community if
you will which again black is a word
that i don't even think entered like the
center of uh the way that we referred to
people in america until
more recent times like the last 40 or 50
years 60 years i don't know
um
but uh
there's been this like big idea that
like when somebody who is considered
black which is still loosely defined
speaks about something intellectual then
that person is a black intellectual and
i think where i get fired up is um you
know like in my comparative politics
class at university of colorado right
now i've got a great professor in that
class but the entire frame of why is the
west so rich is about european dominance
and how that extended itself with the
found you know creation of the united
states but and it's basically anchored
in in this kind of like all right uh
white dominance i'm not gonna say
supremacy because that that's a whole
different conversation i got different
opinions on that but it's all framed in
underneath this kind of lens of white
dominance so
to me if i produce something inside of
academia you know later in my life
or you know in the next couple of years
or if i produce something meaningful out
in society
then what i'm creating is considered
second class because black indicates uh
what people have correlated with a
marginalized group and therefore i can
only respond to people that think about
something in the vein of black
intellectual which also makes a bunch of
assumptions about how i grew up and what
my understanding of blackness is or
isn't and so
i was just frustrated with like the fact
that i feel like there are people that
fit into this category of black
intellectual
that weaponize it
and some of them are you know younger
than me and they've got big channels
um or i would get calls from certain uh
people and media and they would box me
in with uh thinkers that uh you know
they thought uh fit a category based on
race and and i i honestly
i think that's [ __ ] like it's a very
frustrating thing for me
to accept that my thought my thinking
where i'm coming from is basically uh
second rate
uh when we look at the way that um
our society has organized in the way
that it speaks about class and the way
that it speaks about its ability to
interact with political institutions uh
if i think i'm a black intellectual i'm
sure that so i'm sure brian there's a
bunch of ways that
we could talk about this but yeah
yeah because you know i often find it um
look you know as i've said on my channel
many times to neil degrasse tyson my
best friend stefan alexander
you've probably heard it you know jim
gates and i talking about it and i'm
like you know there's no doubt that
blacks pay the black tax i mean you have
to do stuff in academia that i'll never
have to do and and uh uh but you know
and i think there is a burden on me
uh which which is uh which i take
seriously and that i want to find as
many black whatever scientists and and
people in the technical world a because
they have a merit they have a
meritocratic you know stance to be on my
show or in my sphere of influence as as
miniscule or big as that might be but i
also view it as my job and i've had i
think more you know black
scientists on my show
than almost any other podcast i know
about and i'm not saying that to brag
i'm saying i think it's i think we have
to do that just as i have a moral
obligation to communicate to the public
because they pay my salary what i'm
discovering i feel more scientists have
to do that
so too the burden is on me
um not because i think i'm you know
supremacist or racist in any way but i
have to go and solicit you and i i have
to reach out to you and and i do that
and sometimes i get rejected by the way
i've asked you know black scientists you
know no you've had on you know ben
shapiro why would i come on your show
yeah or i've had on you know uh some
some black intellectuals that they don't
like or black scientists whatever um but
i feel it's kind of a double-edged thing
like in academia we're told that
academia is systemically racist
and i don't like that you know it's it's
like if i said well academia's
systemically anti-semitic well what's
the proof of that well you know people
have to work on being anti-anti-semitic
um no i think that's unfalsifiable and
so when i look at um you know people
that uh you know that are doing so much
in the public sphere and they happen to
be black i i really view that as a for
me obviously as a white person i can't
identify in the same way as you but i
view that as insignificant you know your
intellect is what attracts me to you and
i would listen to you if you were you
know whatever or race uh gender color
whatever so
i wonder about this this notion that you
ha you have like people that are spoken
of as black leaders or leaders in the
black community but you don't hear that
about other groups like jewish like i
don't know
first of all you know the old joke is
you know two jews there's three opinions
and uh you know so
how do you react to that statement that
phrase you know black leaders or leader
in the black community is that is that
like also kind of monolithizing you and
and and making you define in this way
that that is anathema to to your
intellectual
accomplishments
yeah it's interesting uh because
i didn't experience this way of talking
about race until after george floyd
so like
i feel like conversations about race
were one way for me before george floyd
and then after george floyd which was a
horrendous scenario but i think that
goes without saying but
the conversations about race in america
seem to change significantly even had
friends call and like apologize crying
and i was like holy [ __ ] like
we've been friends for like a decade
right what are we talking about
right um
so
i've never seen myself as a black leader
and uh i think mixed race being mixed
race is complicated i actually explore
this a little bit in my uh
sub stack of rant and i hope to expand
on this
uh i feel like mixed race identity is
one that gets taken off the table by
people that have more uh
concrete conceptions of self
and uh the black white spectrum
unfortunately is like at the forefront
of political discussions in the united
states even though there are lots of
other people that are not white
necessarily and definitely aren't black
so i think i've inherited this like
complicated identity that my parents
didn't give me any instructions or rule
books for uh how to manage right
yeah
and uh so it makes me straddle this uh
scenario where it's like when i was
younger it was like chris why are you so
black and what the [ __ ] does that mean
and then it would be like why are you so
white and i'm like i really don't
understand what you people are talking
about
and then as i've gotten older and not
felt nearly as insecure about my ethnic
racial
identity whatever you want to call it
i've been able to observe it more and by
the way most people don't think i'm
black which is fascinating wow it's so
incredible
so i get to hear a lot of different
viewpoints because i get treated more as
a member of the in-group even if i'm not
in that group if you know what i'm
saying yeah so i get to hear a lot of
fascinating
viewpoints and i think that
i
i work with a lot of amazing young
people
and uh
and i've worked on a lot of businesses
that i don't talk about just as like
just volunteering helping out in the
community
and maybe um some of these great young
people are black but that's certainly
not the conversation that we have when
we're building something
because i think that the term black
again marks this subservience or this
like second tier or this brain bottom
class and that is the last thing that i
would want to teach young people to
believe about themselves is that they
are inherently less than
because either society
says that out loud um
or because there are certain structures
that are in place that maybe reinforce
that because again i still believe that
we can disrupt some of this thinking or
or we can shift these things in the
future and again a lot of the rhetoric
that comes out about race it's hard to
know if it how much of it is real or
perceived even listening to some of the
different networks on television they
bring the statistics forth in a way that
appeals to their base but that doesn't
necessarily appeal to the truth or the
reality
so i think it's had a big impact on the
way that i think about politics
but maybe not as much of an impact on
how i think about
some of the things that i do in the
corporate setting mm-hmm
yeah very interesting yeah i i didn't
fully appreciate you know that it is
kind of like
uh a further imposition and whether it's
systemic or not we could debate or we
could discuss but but the point of like
um
by just saying black you know whatever
with any other you know subsequent noun
uh after it um it's it's it is an
imposition by maybe a dominant culture
or whatever um but i feel like you know
it
they sh
you know we shouldn't define it you know
or people shouldn't define it the
problem is anything in life you know
eric weinstein points anything it's like
a spectrum is it's very hard for the
human mind to comprehend because it's
like quantum mechanics like we think
classically but like no one's gonna
disagree that before your parents met
you didn't exist and so you couldn't be
aborted say and then after you're born
you know uh you know no one's gonna say
oh well like he's not a he's just a
collection of cells like you're 30 years
old right uh so the point is you know
when there's a harmonic in a
superposition of states that is
ambiguity and the human mind uh likes to
choose black or white literally and
that's what i think has is responsible
for a lot of uh people of mixed uh
heritage that they you know it's the
hardest thing actually in the in the old
testament my tradition you know you're
implored not to be a zealot not to be
too far to the left or too far the right
and why do you have to be commanded to
do something that's natural obviously
you have to be commanded to to love your
kids or your puppy so it must be
unnatural to go down the middle and i
see that as a as a very interesting
skill i want to talk about uh the
newsletter on substance christopher
sweat
um a rant uh which i double subscribed
to uh one of the most fascinating posts
actually happens to be your last post uh
not to put too much pressure on you i
know you've got uh bigger and other
stuff that you're involved with but um i
thought it's fascinating you go back and
you talk about what is natural law what
does that really mean and i think you're
intellectually honest enough to trace it
to its roots and its heritage both in
ancient greece but also back to the god
you know centered world of of europe uh
in the 1600s 1700s john locke one thing
i want to get your reaction to um is the
influence that that thomas jefferson um
was influenced by euclid of all people
so euclid in in his elements
famously says that you know such and
such like two parallel lines don't meet
he says that is self-evident those words
those are in other words you don't even
have to prove it it's so obvio and the
funny thing chris is you probably know
it's not true that two parallel lines
don't meet uh it only happens in
euclidean flat space right so in the
universe it may or may not so he was
actually you know not completely right
about that but but to say something is
self-evident means it's it's beneath
the realm of even having to prove and
yet thomas jefferson as you know in the
declaration of independence refers to
these things what is natural law what is
being self-evident and um do you think
that like politicians should know a
little more mathematic
than they do now or at least logic and
formal philosophy
yeah
100
in fact um and we'll see i think
my thoughts are still being discovered
on this but
i think that natural laws like the uh uh
the crux of
arguments that happen in american
politics yes
if we just stop watching what's on
television or in the news media
um when i think about the laws of nature
like you were saying these seem to be
like really christian conceptions of uh
rules or constraints
that are placed upon us i guess you
could say on a on a basic level
and i think that a lot of people that
have thought about natural law over many
years make valid points in certain ways
like like maybe
maybe it is self-evident that um uh
everyone should have access to life
liberty and justice like like maybe that
okay fine like like we all assume that
it's a duh that everyone should have
access to these three basic principles
of democracy life liberty and justice
duh
okay
um i think the issue is that
natural
law
is going to exclude people
that aren't capable uh in whatever the
current state of the environment is of
producing
something that um creates some kind of
value right
and uh i think this is where a lot of
political conversations break down on
the environment or on social justice is
that you have two parties that have
different interpretations of these
natural constraints these self-evident
things
you know
things that are supposed to be
um but maybe aren't
uh and you've got one side that says um
it's the
republicans that
are
preventing us from solving these really
meaningful
social and environmental issues
and then you have uh the other side that
says it's the democrats that prevent us
from addressing these important issues
and it seems like the republican
thinking in american politics is going
to try to trace back to some level of
status quo
which means let's keep these uh this
these things that are self-evident going
let's not pursue any type of like
government intervention
let's not
try to redistribute wealth or disrupt
this current structure of existing
but again if all society have some type
of inequity in them then that way of
thinking
seems out of line with solving some of
what people would say are the most
important problems you know happening
right now again around social justice or
the environment
um but i also think you know
the
these like
the left we call it uh which i think is
over simplified and maybe gives too much
credit but like american liberals
are pretending that they're constrained
by republicans when in reality they're
constrained by the constitution yeah so
i'm trying to frame this i'm trying to
frame this argument of
both of these parties are constrained by
this idea of natural law
and it seems like
if our law doesn't account for social or
environmental constraints it's no wonder
that it can't address social or
environmental issues and again like what
is when people talk about policy what
are they talking about they're not
they're talking about the government
printing money it's obvious that the
government has instituted different
policies like you know the civil rights
act of 1964 or 1971 for example 1971 was
supposed to integrate schools
but in reality all it said was that it
was illegal to separate people based on
race inside of these schools but that
didn't really change the way that
society behaved in the environment or
the way that people interacted with
other groups it didn't change as much of
the thinking as i think people give it
credit for so i'm just i'm trying to get
to the root of um
uh kind of issues that i'm observing
where the constitution has these ideas
that are ambitious
and uh they've been taught to us as uh
self-evident and which i think um is
similar to like if you're in a church
and you're not allowed to ask questions
about the scripture
and uh for the first time i'm kind of
looking at this and i'm like okay
there's some real constraints banked
into the way that uh our constitution
set up and both parties are talking
around it and there also seem to be
other more complicated systems that
interact with american politicians
the federal government on a regular
basis that add additional complexity and
like you said earlier i'm exploring this
um
in near real time because i'm trying to
kind of balance out like my
uh
like how much i like to write and how
much i like to express myself in that
medium but then also still bring some uh
academic rigor right i don't i'm not
trying to make it just all opinion if
you will no it's uh erudite early
research is cited
uh original sources i love that you're
thinking in public and you're writing in
public i think it's the hardest thing to
do but i think in this day and age it's
one of the most valuable things we can
do not only for ourselves but for
everybody yeah just to reference your
point you know as i was reading it and
thinking about this tension that you
keep referring to in that piece um i was
thinking about las vegas odds bookmakers
you know because they don't make any
money if my kids little league team
plays the
vaunted san diego padres or your
colorado rockies um not doing so hot now
but but anyway uh but
uh but if if they play this they're
gonna get blown out my kids are gonna
get crushed right so what do they do
they have a point spread and what's the
analog of the point spread nobody makes
money unless there's the point spread is
evenly matched so it boosts up so what
does the media do they make the
narrative equal and not like you know uh
it's a tight race and it's
bitterly divided and everything they
won't make any any money if you're like
oh it's it's a total blood like american
opinions like cully against this opinion
or this this statue um in the in the
last 10 minutes or so uh you also think
and write a lot about uh finance uh
future tech you know venture capital
things like that uh i want to get uh
first of all i can't resist because it's
always in the news and i've had on
guests like michael saylor and and uh
and and kind of his his evil you know
twin peter schiff who's kind of on the
opposite side of things economically uh
gold i don't know what to do chris um so
what do you think about like all these
this this pace again of technology now
it's it's in the currency network effect
um not just in social and in online what
do you make of opportunities uh you know
i can't resist you know asking you about
about blockchain and so forth where do
you see this going and more
provocatively are there opportunities
for people in academia like myself to
somehow utilize this for the benefit of
humanity
yeah okay so
there are certain things that i won't be
able to speak on effectively here
because i've distanced myself from a lot
of the blockchain hype yeah me too yeah
okay like um
that that aside though obviously i've
been listening on a regular basis to the
different arguments that people make for
uh not necessarily blockchain but um
cryptocurrency to like replace uh fiat
currency i've been listening to these
arguments for four or five years now and
i mean i have friends that mine and so
forth
and i i have a friend that has stood up
a decent mining operation in kansas city
like i mean it's pretty legit looking at
like
how a mining operation works and
how data analytics can play into it and
how scientific it can get so i think
like if people can find ways to make
money in these new
technology environments they should like
i would always encourage that
um i just ne i just oh i just don't
think that it's smart to over index and
if people are looking at it from an
investment
uh again not giving any investment
advice here even though i don't have any
licenses for that anyway
uh i don't think anybody should over
index on one asset class if people are
making their
investments
as far as blockchain goes uh again as
with any kind of technology the more
advanced it gets the more operations
it's going to require like a department
of people that are able to support it
and have a specific set of skills and
capabilities
so i i'm optimistic you know that we'll
find ways to integrate these
technologies but but trying to
integrate the newer technologies like
that being my practice for the last like
seven or eight years like
something i've been dedicated to
uh it's not simple and and uh
it's hard to see through the hype yeah
so but but i always i'm always
optimistic i just don't think it's smart
to over index for the people that are
making money currently on these
different technologies they should keep
doing that
what about yeah talk about venture
capital and and where why does that
appeal to you
um you know it seems to me like again
there's so many barriers to entry
there's so many gatekeepers you know
it's very hard i mean robin hood what
are we gonna do i mean so but talk about
it what is it what does it appeal to you
why should you turn your you know
limited amount of time but vast
intellectual capital towards this this
you know relatively challenging modality
to to uh to at least have some degree of
aspirational wealth
yeah no i think um i started my first
business when i was 19.
and uh i i had some success we'll talk
about it some other time but it it was
enough success to make me over confident
it basically took me another eight or
nine years to actually build a decent
business that could turn a profit and
provide for me
and uh that was kind of my quest of like
understanding as much about business as
i possibly could
and come to find out and this is one of
the reasons why i decided to go back to
university but come to find out the
access to you know technology the bay
area startups venture capital the access
to these things the the things that are
needed to start um legitimate
entrepreneurial ventures especially the
ones that um are in the vein of
technology it's very constricted
and so i i had gone in and out of enough
tech companies and seen enough
iterations of software and seen a lot of
companies grow and become very dominant
over the last decade where once they had
these like really basic primitive tools
that weren't that exciting and next
thing you know they're like in 80 of the
global 2000 and so i wanted to know like
why that was happening what was the
what was the trajectory and i came to
learn that venture capital uh list
venture capital list their funds they
are not able to manage risk in a
systematic way so they use a hand-waving
heuristic to decide where they place
their funds and so they're obviously
going to place their funds with people
that go to you know 10 or 12
universities and maybe very rarely
outside of that come through certain
circles of friends and because of the
way that they
make their investments they need outsize
returns which means that they're only
able to invest in companies that have a
outsized
total addressable market a place that
they can sell the service to and i'm
like well that's interesting that this
venture capital that really only can
invest in very specific business models
and invest only in very specific types
of individuals
you know is considered like this iconic
form of american capitalism which i
think couldn't be further from the truth
um and so
so anyways uh when i'm speaking about
different things especially being as
outspoken as i can
around technology or software of the bay
area
venture capital i just like to
understand like there's a certain
capital structure behind these
technologies and it obviously um it has
a big impact on uh what what these
technologies can produce in the near
term
um and and it has a big influence on you
know what's possible down the road and
so i again i can't look at one part of
the system and not try to look at a few
other parts of the system to understand
what's going on
well uh christopher sweat we have had a
fascinating conversation i could
certainly talk to you
for many more hours i'm looking forward
to sunday meeting in person i don't
think all relationships should stay
online and i hope to meet you maybe when
i'm out at nist and my colleagues at
boulder yes and for now i just want to
encourage everybody to read uh
chris's sub stack which is phenomenal
and i'd like to get some advice on
myself someday about doing a sub stack i
haven't started that i have a newsletter
but not a sub stack so please subscribe
to that show notes will contain the link
information follow me on twitter
clubhouse instagram
uh linkedin everywhere that social media
profiles can be seen i follow him
religiously and chris it's just such a
pleasure i'm so glad you accepted my
invitation and uh i hope we can have
many more conversations
on online and off and uh i just want to
congratulate you again courage is a rare
commodity
and uh and i really whenever i see kind
of you light up on clubhouse or whatever
it's a it's a must tune in so keep up
the awesome work my friend
thank you so much brian this was fun i
appreciate it
have a great rest of your day and uh i
hope again see you soon chris see you
soon brian
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic